wait
uh boy that's very very different you
know so we've had eddie brian miguel and
horon here
for south africa region
quite the variety in topping yeah
wild character variety here you know i
was talking earlier when we started the
stream about you know whether we'd fill
out the dlc characters and instead we've
seen none of them for the winter side of
the bracket right only on the lunar side
look at the damage that was four seconds
misses the follow-up doesn't matter
going for that backlash really
brandishing it out there
man he gets tall he is towering over
i've never noticed how much taller he is
maybe it's his hair
he is way taller than laura
he's probably taller than martin he's
probably tighter than [ __ ] wrong too
just like everyone else's
just like everyone else yup
not as advertised
it's like that that meme is like hey mom
can we get [ __ ] wrong we got [ __ ]
mom at home
oh here we go nice plasma blade
follow up here
here we go we got the wall
nice talk
ready for it full launch punish here dvk
whoa how do you get away from there
no bro
here we go tied up on rounds
[Music]
man that was that all started with that
very very clean whiff punish they trade
blows there
[Music]
again
sometimes you just gotta throw it out
there that back oh my gosh the art of
interruption dude that was a crazy
backfield put in that position
try to test them there went for the mid
launch
transition parabellum kicks the
follow-up
oh
and dbk didn't believe in that one
launch would have been the round but
here we go get the throw
he went for the low bbk up two rounds to
one here let's see what droopy does what
kind of adjustment
he's been playing pretty well i mean
he's been getting all those hits but
those those uh folks ended up adding up
you got to break those throws
oh the big boot that's the bounce
do it again yup in the chest
that's not the wall it's a good time
instead of doing bob's belly you might
as well
nice now the lows are coming out the one
thing that we really haven't seen from
droopy is the use of the lows to kind of
open up his opponent uh oh oh my god
come back oh don't get a problem
run up and just do the low for the race
drive
reset the situation is going to go for
it low jab oh my god
erotic hair
drive
boom
combo
wall boom perfect combo from dvk
smart stuff miguel
getting it done here
yeah and of course having that ranger
i've really helped uh if he hadn't had
that he wouldn't have gotten a screw
otherwise so he was able to pull it off
and good stuff to dvk taking that first
game here in our in our winter side
match yeah that erotic error is uh been
very important the last couple of games
that we've seen the last couple rounds
we've seen uh but very nice stuff to dvk
the miguel's looking clean you can tell
that both of these players it looks like
they've played each other before that's
what i'm seeing i feel like they're very
familiar with the matchups uh the
punishers are on deck you know they're
ready to go uh especially each of the
tendencies but uh i'm still impressed
with what we've seen so far out of uh
droopy and dbk right that the back three
passenger interrupt that he did i was
like whoa that was something you
wouldn't normally do just against any
other player unless you knew what they
were going for specifically you know
especially since this is launch
punishable too it's like you're throwing
out a huge risk there but still he had
the confidence and you know i'm pretty
sure he hit most of them he did if not
all of them in in the set
oh yeah
man
uh anyways
we're gonna go back in there droopy uh i
don't think we'll see a character change
i think we'll see more horung um again
big match here to get into our winners
finals this is definitely a position you
want to be in obviously you know you're
going to lose bracket you have to play
way more matches so
uh especially in top eight very very
important as we go into this
here we go brimstone and fire
fire
yeah sticking out hurong definitely his
main
i'm not going to be switching away from
it you can see the the letter grades
there looking like he's got some good
grades miguel's grades not so hot didn't
do so well in school ccd come on
i gotta say like um the the south
african community they're very active at
least in the offline scene you know we
see a lot of clips and we see a lot of
uh stuff from them through uh online on
twitter and stuff like that we see a lot
of their their events and their
tournaments uh i wonder if maybe just
online is not something that they do too
often i mean i've noticed like i guess
based on the ranks that i've seen from a
lot of these players maybe they don't
play ranked maybe they just play player
matches but either way it's nice to see
of course these players going at it
there's the wall just short of it
yeah the ranks are definitely not an
indicator of their skill level oh yeah
nice duck and launch again
and you can see he's got a lot of
experience either against the character
or against groupies in particular right
because his his launches are just locked
loaded ready to go every time
uh-huh goes for the wall setting four
fourth
oh my gosh he took some damage there
this is what i want to see though i want
to see droopy start going for more of
these low attacks more of these risks to
really help him he gets the wall this
time that's gonna hit
nice ward 4-3 looking to close him out
and goes for the mid
there you go there's that round
sometimes juan needs that momentum
yeah the fishing for these backlash from
the distance really hasn't been working
out for them
nice try nice ride a little bit late
here we go nice good block
oh but that big boot again at the wall
you might as well do it
double low jab to close it out man here
we go dvk one round away from moving on
let's see what he does here jupiter is
really gonna have to turn things up
[Music]
oh my god i could have had something
there
[Music]
oh he's at the wall he's got to be
careful he back dash while in flamingo
he's dead
hell is dead and that will be that quick
work for dvk
to guarantee himself
a winner's final position here very
nicely done dvk droopy sent on down to
loser bracket not out of the tournament
though uh but you can tell there dbk you
really